لا تزال الاشتباكات مستمره في ولايات
مختلفه في السودان بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع طبعا بعد ان وصلت المحادثات الى
طريق مسدود بين الطرفين الطرفين اتفقا على
شيء واحد وهو ان هذه الاشتباكات ستنتهي
سريعا لكن المشهد على الارض لا يوحي
بنهايه قريبه فبينما اعلن الجيش عن
استسلام قوات من الدعم السريع في مواقع
مختلفه اضافه الى قصف معسكراته يتحدث
الدعم السريع ايضا عن سيطرته على قواعد
عسكريه في الخرطوم وفي غيرها من المناطق
السودانيه كما اعلن ايضا عن اغلاق كل
المنافذ جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم ووسط كل هذا
تدعو معظم دول العالم رعاياها الى
الالتزام باماكنها الى عدم الخروج في
المناطق المفتوحه خصوصا بعد ان علقت معظم
شركات الطيران العالميه رحلتها الى
الخرطوم وبشكل مؤقت حتى تتكشف نتائج ما
يحدث هذا اليوم